nice to come nei video dai bella a tutti
i ragazzi venuti a questo nuovo video
lui e fa vj oggi siamo su italia 1 per
parlare bene di essere sciolto però va
bene lo stesso alla ragazzi siamo con i
babbo ho pensato di fare un video
abbastanza figo ovvero dei presenti quiz
che faccio io su me stesso insomma il
problema sai quale è che se sbaglia a
fare qualcosa
dopo esserci lasciò le penne in diretta
poi c'è la facevo le vie o 5 milioni di
visualizzazioni perché non lo metti di
che reputo che fa più ci sei
ci sono bene senti un attimo risulta
adesso dovrebbe funzionare ma io nuovo
testo perché sono una brava persona
allora il gioco consigliera quando
indovini niente scorsa quando non
indovini la scossa è istantanea nel
video di oggi 12 agosto di che colorerà
la sua maglia è mica un video di oggi 12
agosto che cosa colera la casa rossa a
c'è uno show un indicibile
come si chiama il padre di non è
possibile il trattato è più di uno
sbaglio questa tira una palla
elettroshock
come si chiama viali l'alieno parlante
che fa di jay o
questa è una bella domanda da tempo ai
20 secondi al quale a dirmi
lp per felice quando ha fatto la drive
my life
la card draw my lai pro lisce speciale
45 mila iscritti anzi fortissimo rumore
culo chiama mamma che non ricavare
quanti anni a famiglie e ma questo di
adesso giusto che ne so io non sono
responsabile anche schifo e domani
prendi tre punti ma mi piace le famiglie
in quanti media fatto con i match che
non sai madonna 12 nov la regia è
all'asta basta ho fatto così una volta
scuola cioè no more stagione così male
la prova di geni che colore al telefono
era difficile questa domanda chi sa non
guardare il telefono mentre rispondi
arpe sa che io guardavo rito ed apple
non lo cercavo se sei un genio a cosa
gioca fa il gene pino video all'interno
del suo canale parigi è ormai finito
impossibili game non l'ha mai fatto
perderebbe a questi bella n'era andata
era andato anche prima perché sapevo che
avresti sbagliato per quello che non ha
effetti collaterali mani e braccia
romani 2 gela e questa è bella questa
bella al prestatore si sa bene perché
speciale ha fatto just dance con la sua
ragazza 150 300 100 a 150 mila iscritti
ma che culo dai non è possibile non ha
ricordava mentre resta più o meno perché
ha deciso di fare lo youtube per
guadagnare soldi per farsi conoscere per
stampare solo isabelle per francesi
esempi strappare un sorriso le persona
ma per guadagnare soldi hai sbagliato
come si chiama di cognome fa vj uccelli
uccelli sbagliato a chiamiamola mamma
facciamogli fare questa cosa bella mamma
vieni a fare un gioco bello ha detto di
sì ha detto dai vieni a fare questo
gioco bello una volta ti prego ti prego
una volta mangio tutto
mangio le cose vado anche a fare la
stella mangia la frutta
dopo cena promesso la verdura ma adesso
si vede la scorsa per in uno scatto per
tu sei tutto quello che devi sapere su
di me quindi non devi neanche avere
pochi papa non l'ha presa mai la rezza
giovani della fascia non trovarci duro e
dove sono donna non urla io support fa
vj e un grande amico di simone facendo
mezzi joker ciccio gamer da che li
conosce niente brava avere che l'età è
leggo è allora che il problema jerkin il
pesciolino che aveva da piccolo fra vj
minchiatti meriti la scossa cento la
inciso tu
almeno quello non è possibile ma vige
con quale youtuber straniero ha fatto
una foto mark player v2 non si conosco
quello che fa le cose di calcio più di
pai o chiesa è finita e non so se è
bastato spesso anche di pai dai 27
secondi sei sbagliare perché sono donna
non urla io supporto dai toni capito che
era la foto ma player ma se ti piace di
più dai tutela ma fuori ma fa malissimo
fosse la pensa che lo sto tenendo a uno
di cento
bisogna soffrire no dai dai che quando
hai partorito è fatto che quando fa vj
invece da ciampi bagni per la prima
volta questo è l'anno dai divani chiami
maniera quella degli cosi che ti metti
in bocca perché io faccio le cose
intelligenti sul mio canale iscrivetevi
tutti quanti ma cosa era questa
copertina di un video e uno di due
famosi che ho fatto che hai visto
ovviamente per l'ultima che iniziò da
greta fa vj nella sfida caramelle tutti
i gusti più uno per fargli capire che
sta mangiando la caramella ad
marshmallow fa vigenti ha fatto la pro
facciata legino mi voglio dire con i
seggi voglio solo vivere cantella sei
mesi con fabio ragazzi con martedì fate
visse una marca di pennarelli mappe
visconi mail mi chiamo è possibile ma
cosa che adesso l'academy ha fatto un
video intitolato ho davvero una ragazza
no no io sono donna non urla io sopporto
un bagno
va bè ragazzi io per concludere di tempo
di fare una sfida finale me ne sto per
pentire come lo schifo che loro due
adesso mi fanno una domanda è se io
risponde l'ho sbagliato mela becco io
sono perché sono l'uomo vero non si
ricomincia bruttissimo mi sa che crepo
quail batteries ma non mi farebbe stato
ma che cazzo di solito ha detto il
batterista dei generi disk e catello
phil collins porco demonio nice un
raggio sul braccio primo presidente
degli stati uniti il primissimo no è che
ti prendi thomas jefferson e lazio ci
vuole ma lo sapevo la ragionevole perché
ho detto tomasi e chiedi ma bastano cosa
chiedi quale animale acquatico più
grande del terno l'animale più grande
del mondo ha un nome la balena qua ci
sono le balena grosso da balena grossa
la balena grossa più più forza cazzo ne
so papa la balenottera azzurra andava
bene la maniera non basta visto noto già
chi sono io che ho deciso di farlo pure
mi ha lasciato un segno
se cioè il segno più grosso va bene
ragazzi basta è stato il gioco veramente
pietoso che ho deciso di fare io
benissimo niente ragazzi di ignazio i
genitori per aver partecipato a questo
punto splendido ea me stesso per aver
avuto questa idea meravigliosa veni
ragazzi spero in questo video vi sia
piaciuto
giunge al momento è un mi piace anche i
vari social che come nei video
tradizione si scateni ci dimettiamo il
prossimo video concludono questo
telecomando che mi sembra abbastanza
come sono e ci vediamo il prossimo video
da te la data non sono donna nulla io
sopporto
[Musica]